megkérdezzük a a c gpt-t valamiről és
azt tapasztaljuk hogy hogy nem a
valóságot adja vissza hanem hanem
kitalál valamit ennek az oka ez ez
nagyon egyszerű hogyha valamire nem
tudja a pontos választ egy nagynyelvű
modell akkor egy olyan választ próbál
generálni ami legalábbis hihető mert ő ő
mindig a hibát próbálja minimalizálni
mindig próbálja elkerülni a hibát és a a
valami az mindig kevesebb hiba mint a
semmi tehát hogyha semmit nem vál
valamire az az mindig maximális hiba
lesz tehát az a az az hogy ne
válaszoljon semmit az az software bug
egy egy nagynyelvi modellnél az
összeomlik a modellekes hogy ez az
embereknél is pont így van tehát a
tétlenség az nagyobb hiba mintogyha
hibásan elkezdünk és valamit valamit
elkezdünk cselekedni mert utólag aztán
tudjuk korrigálni az utunkat de hogyha
el se indulunk akkor valójában valójában
ez a legnagyobb hiba